What the fuck is up, guys? Welcome to our first ever official YouTube video.
If you don't know who we are, we are PB Trading.
I'm Patrick.
I'm Blake.
And that's what PB Trading is.
Maybe you know us from the skits online or maybe you know us from the Discord.
We have a trading Discord and we also make comedy videos on the internet.
If you find those videos funny, it's probably because you related to them once.
We all have been there.
We've all full ported accounts before.
We've all blown fucking 100 accounts.
We all started at rock bottom.
But we want to get more serious here.
I want to give you guys essentially an ICT for dummies series,
which is all you will ever need to achieve profitability.
I guarantee you guys, if you just watch this from the start to the finish,
this is literally going to be all you need.
Scrap everything that you ever have learned or seen in any YouTube video.
We're going to teach it to you in a way where even your fucking grandma could learn this.
I mean, I learned how to trade through Blake.
All right.
I was able to understand his strategy in maybe two to three months.
And it's the most digestible thing ever.
It's easy.
When information is filtered, it's easy to understand, right?
A huge problem just with any information online.
So there's so much of it online and you don't know what to look for.
You don't know what to consume.
That's why we're here.
We're here to filter this for you and structure it in a way where it's essentially.
Why do we just get more where it's going to speed run this profitability process, right?
And we're not saying like rushing the process or leaving out information.
We're just not adding unnecessary information.
We're making this as efficient as possible.
All right.
And I think you guys deserve like a little introduction.
So my name is Blake.
I've been trading for four years now.
I made my first hundred thousand dollars trading when I was 19 years old.
How I started was pretty much just like you guys.
I bet you guys searched up how to start trading on YouTube.
First video I saw was this dude named Warrior Trading.
I don't know if any of you guys have seen him.
Turns out he was a complete fraud.
He got sued by the FTC for three point five million dollars.
And I was learning from him.
And that was that was my start.
And I was learning basically just options.
You know, I flipped 5K into 12K.
Lucky.
Yeah.
Lucky like I was not.
I had no.
When I tell you guys I had zero clue what I was doing, like zero clue.
Like I would remember going into this dude's like YouTube because he used to do like free
YouTube live streams.
He would show you like like the stocks that he was looking at.
Bro, I would literally be like, yo, what time does market open?
It says like nine thirty.
I'm like bet.
So I'll just like buy the stock at nine thirty open.
Thinking like that's what you're supposed to do.
Bro, I worked out for a bit.
This kid visited me my first year in college and he just showed up decked out in chrome.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I'm like, where'd you even get all this jewelry from?
Yeah.
You ended up selling that.
And like a matter of like a few days, I had to sell all of that.
Yeah, I ended up blowing all that money.
I was basically all the money that I saved up from when I was working.
Working at this job at this place called Care Express.
I was cleaning dishes fucking 24 seven.
I smelled like straight bleach and shit all the time.
My boss, like everything sucked about the job.
And I remember like there was one night I was taking out the trash
and it was like a five minute walk to the dumpster.
Trash just spilled all over me, all on my back.
At this point, I'm like, I have to put it in the dumpster,
but there's just smoothie juice like all over my back and all on the ground.
So I'm like trying to pick it up.
It's like nine p.m.
It was like, no, it was like past closing time, bro.
I was so late and it sucked.
And then my boss outed me the next morning.
He comes to me, he's like, Blake, I saw you on the security cam footage.
Like in front of everyone, in front of everyone.
Like you left all the trash out and I'm like,
there's nothing I could have done, brother.
It's like smoothie juice.
He's like, well, you got fined by this.
We got fined by the state or by the city, like three hundred dollars.
And I'm taking it out of your check.
And I'm like, bro, like that is literally like the three hundred dollars.
I made like three hundred dollars a month.
Like that's that's what I was making.
Like three to four hundred dollars a month, bro.
At that moment, I was like, dude, fuck this job.
Fuck this.
I've saved up enough money because at the end of the day,
I wanted to be my own boss.
I don't want to have a boss.
So I saved up all that money.
Really, the first thing I started doing was searching up online.
The second I got home, how to start making money online.
SMMA, tried that, failed.
Drop shipping, tried that, failed.
Every single side hustle you could think of.
I was even doing fucking pressure washing for around my place just to like get more money.
I was actually doing that for a while.
Then I eventually found trading and fell in love with it.
It was really the only thing that stuck with me.
Shortly after that, I found ICT concepts, right?
So this was six months in.
And I mean, ICT, like it was the only thing that made sense in my head.
Support and resistance.
There's no like narrative behind it.
With ICT, there's always like a story behind like every trade that you're taking.
So it really made sense in my head and it kind of like changed the way I view trading.
And I think like that's like really the goal.
We're going to explain it to you in ways that not only make sense like technically,
but logically as well.
Because that's the way Blake explained it for me when he was teaching me.
So I mean, I don't know if I mentioned this already, but Blake essentially mentored me.
He's my best friend growing up for maybe the last fuck, I don't know, eight years.
Eight fucking years, maybe more.
One day we were on a trip together over summer.
We're just hanging out.
He shows me his phone.
He's like, yo, look at this shit.
I just made fucking thousand dollars.
I'm like, what?
How did you just make a thousand dollars?
We're posted up right now on the beach and he's just like, yeah, I just made a band.
I'm like, dude, teach me.
I didn't even say teach me.
I said, let me copy you.
And I think like everyone, that's like sort of everyone's first instinct.
When they see someone like make money, you just kind of want the easy route.
And Blake kept it straight up with me.
And he was like, no, I'm not letting you copy me,
but I will send you over every single video I've watched.
You can watch them learn and then I'll help you.
You know what I mean?
But first, you need to understand.
You need to build your foundation.
And I was like, all right, fair enough.
And so he sent me hundreds, thousands of fucking videos.
I watched every single one.
And then I would FaceTime him every single morning, market open.
And I'd have him there on FaceTime.
And he'd be like helping me sort of go about the trades.
He wouldn't just be like, yo, I'm in now.
But he'd be like, yeah, like this looks good.
This looks good.
And shout out pack because he's like the only person I've had in my life
that when I tell them what to do.
So when I was in college and I was like making a shit ton of money,
obviously all my friends were asking me like, yo, put me on.
What are you doing?
And I'm like, what's the method?
Whatever, right?
And I would tell them like, yo, this is what you have to do.
And I'll give them what they have to do.
Watch these videos.
It's going to be a pain in the ass.
Do this.
Nobody went through with it.
Patrick and I was thinking like, yeah, I'm
going to send him these videos, bro.
And like, it's going to be another story, you know?
And eventually, bro, he just kept up with me every day.
And I was like, fuck it.
I love this.
I love teaching people.
And he was obviously locked in.
He's a smart as fuck.
Bro, it's just like awesome having someone there side by side with you
who you trust, who you can see their success right in front of you.
And it makes it feel that much more possible.
Because I knew he was, I was just like, dude, this kid's fucking killing it.
Like, there's no reason I can't do it.
Having like an accountability partner like Blake or something like that,
just to keep you motivated, to keep you ambitious, to keep you on track
is so fucking amazing in life.
And we want to build that relationship with you guys through these videos,
like through this series.
And it's going to be fucking amazing.
Anyways, I tried like a million entrepreneurial ventures growing up.
I mean, the idea of obviously being independent,
letting my creativity navigate my success was so cool to me.
I tried starting a clothing brand.
I think that was like my biggest really venture ever that I went through with.
I did it for about a year and a half, two years.
And it went well.
I saw like short term success with it.
I was making decent amount of money for a bit,
but I could never figure out how to make it sustainable.
Just wasn't there.
It's like such a, it's fucking hard, bro.
It's a lot of luck involved.
I also tried drop shipping.
Didn't fucking work.
I tried, you know, investing in crypto early as fuck.
I didn't know what I was doing.
Um, lost my money.
I took like a year off university to just only trade.
And it was the best decision I ever made.
Obviously I had a skill that I had honed and I didn't want to put it to waste.
Everything I tried, I kind of just lost my money,
but that's not a bad thing.
Like failure is inevitable.
And you learn something from all those things.
You just need to keep trying until something fucking clicks.
Like a lot of you guys have this horrible, horrible connotation with failing
and you tie it to worthlessness that you're not going to get anywhere and,
and all this bullshit, but you need to realize that like,
you're going to fail a million fucking times.
Life is dead ass like trading.
What does a bullish fucking move look like?
It's up and down, but you keep getting higher every single time
that you make another low, right?
You break that high every single fucking time.
And you got to be the same way with anything in life.
No success on this planet is linear.
Never will you see linear success.
Like you're going to fucking hit these new lows.
Your job is to never make that low lower than the one before.
That's all you need to know.
I kind of want to like look at you guys
and I want you to answer this for yourself.
Do you fucking want this, right?
Do you actually want to succeed or are you just looking for short-term gain?
Are you looking for quick money?
Because if that's what you're looking for,
you're not going to make a fucking dollar with trading.
This isn't one of those things where like you just magically make money after two weeks.
It requires you putting your fucking head down
and actually enjoying every second of the process.
Whether it is fucking hard, whether you are not seeing results,
you need to enjoy that.
Nothing in life that is rewarding is easy.
Take the time to sit down and ask yourself those three questions.
Do I really want this?
Why do I want this?
And how the fuck am I going to get there?
And we're not here to only just make you better traders.
We want to make you better people as well.
Let's give you a quick breakdown of what you can expect with this ICT for Dummies course.
Blake has a list right here.
He's going to go over it.
First off, guys, we're going to just do like a quick introduction to futures.
And then we're going to basically just go over every single ICT concept.
If you are brand new, like complete beginner in a trading,
we are going to be helping you with that.
All right, so we have candlesticks.
We're going to go over market structure.
We're going to go over, again, every ICT concept.
So fibs, liquidity for value gaps, order blocks, breaker blocks, CISD, SMT,
time risk management, market maker models, daily bias,
understanding manipulation, recognizing market conditions due to swings.
We're going to go over my model,
which is my mechanical model that I teach every single day in our Discord.
And I'm also going to go over my discretionary model
and also has over a 70% win rate.
We'll also be going over my model, which is a PDI model.
I mean, if you're in the Discord, you obviously know this model
and it's super fucking easy to understand.
It kind of plays off Blake's mechanical model.
We're going to talk about your success plan, how to journal.
We're going to go over pro firms and brokers, of course,
how to pass a pro firm and get a payout,
plenty of psychology lessons.
This is crucial.
As you guys know, trading isn't just technical.
It's very psychology-based.
At this bootcamp, guys, I want you to be fully locked in.
Know that every single video that we're going to be putting out here
is for a fucking reason.
It's everything that I've known and that I need to know
to be a profitable trader.
Anyways, guys, we want you to get fucking hyped
because it really is possible, dude.
It's fucking possible and it's not hard
when you have the right information and the right people.
Fucking god, this shit.
It is not hard, bro.
I am a dumbass, bro.
He is a dumbass.
I'm telling you guys, this shit is possible.
There is a statistic where it is 99% of people
do not make it in day trading.
What is that statistic based off, though?
It's going to be the people that don't do what they're told to do.
When we're telling you right now, watch everything.
We're going to give you homework every night.
Do all of the homework, right?
The people that don't make it, that are part of the 99%,
are most likely going to start dropping off.
What do the 1% do?
They have discipline.
Not only on the charts, which we're going to teach you how,
but in your day-to-day life.
If you're not even going to the gym every single day,
I'm going to tell you this straight up,
or fucking making your bed,
or doing the easy shit in life, bro.
Trading is not for you.
I'm going to be straight up.
I'm going to tell you, click off this video,
stop watching this, go try something else.
If you're watching this video and you grew up
playing video games or some shit,
because I can tell you personally,
I've invested thousands of hours into video games,
CSGO, Rocket League, and all this shit growing up.
When I wanted to learn how to trade,
I told myself there is absolutely zero reason
why I can't have that same devotion
to a skill that's going to change my life.
This is not something I was going to put to waste.
This is obviously a skill I wanted to be good at.
And I made that a promise to myself.
I made it a promise that with that success,
I'd be able to support my friends, my family, travel,
and do everything I ever fucking wanted to.
We really just want to teach people
who actually give a fuck and want to change their lives.
We know a lot of you probably hate the position
you are in right now.
And that's probably why you're watching this video.
I fucking hated the position I was in.
I also can't thank enough Blake for what he taught me.
We're really living our fucking dream now.
Once you learn how to make your first thousand dollars,
the next 10,000 comes easier.
And then before you know it, bro,
you got a hundred thousand dollars in your bank account.
The beginning is always the hardest and slowest process.
But if you can just sit through those fucking boring chapters,
things get real fucking fun.
If you've made it this far into this video,
do me a favor right now.
Go into the comment section.
Tell me your story.
It can be a short story.
And make a promise to yourself at the end of this.
Say in six months or in three months,
this is where I'm going to be.
This is how my day to day is going to look like.
And if you can look back at this comment
and actually be practicing everything that you preach there,
congratulations, bro.
You're going to see success in everything you do in your life.
And meet that fucking goal.
Because I fucking believe in you.
Blake believes in you.
I fucking believe in Blake.
All right.
And like Blake said, bro, I think this is...
I tell everyone this.
Never say anything negative about yourself.
You need to wake up every fucking morning and tell yourself,
I'm rich.
I'm happy.
I'm loving.
I'm successful.
I'm great.
I'm amazing.
Bro, fucking brainwash yourself.
It is so important.
That's how I've gotten every single thing I've ever fucking wanted in life.
It's because I actually told myself I'd fucking do it.
I don't say I wish this.
I don't give a fuck, bro.
If I want something, I fucking have it already.
Your future is written if you believe in yourself.
It's all already fucking carved in.
It is etched into the ground.
There is a story about you.
And you're just going to bring that shit to life.
You're going to take the same steps that your future self,
your future successful self took to get there.
There is no reason you can't do it.
You know exactly what you need to do in life to become successful.
You know exactly every step you need to take.
So every day that goes by where you're not taking those steps,
you need to fucking slap yourself in the face and wake up because it's possible.
Anyways, now you know our names.
Patrick, Blake.
We're PB Trading and we're going to make sure we change your fucking life.
All right, boys.
We'll see you guys for the next video.
It's going to be on Introduction to Futures.
Get your fucking notebooks out.
It's going to be a good one.
And yeah.
Fuck yeah, guys.